Một công tên nơi bất ngờ dời xuống kênh chợ gạo sau khi xa lan trở hàng
buứng dây điện mắt nhanh sông.
Sư việc xa xa xa mở bà thật mà người đàn ông điều khiển xa lan trở
muốn lắp công tên nơi sống rí chuyển từ gấm đàn đó xa đồng sân về vàng
kỳ hôn xa bình nình khi đi qua của vực cầu trở gạo sòn nước lớn và
chuyển trở công trí báo hiệu đường truyền rồi điện lắp công tên nơi
trên cùng vướng báo xây điện khiến một công tên nơi xuống kênh
xe cố không kênh thịt hải bên rồi.
Công tên nơi dời xuống kênh đã được tổ chức trụ bất
Cơ quan công an xa điện, người nhân bàn đầu nha thuyền trường không tôn thuộc
các chỉ giảm của bảo vệ đường tuy của điện khi điện khi điện khi tên quan
của cầu trở gạo, đưa việc đang được làm gió.